>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Joan Weeks: So, good
afternoon ladies and gentlemen,
on behalf of my colleagues
and in particular Dr. Mary Jane Depp
[phonetic], Chief of the African
and Middle Eastern Division,
unfortunately she can't
be with us today.
I'd like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone.
I'm Joan Weeks, head of
the [inaudible] section of
and the sponsor of today's program.
And we are very pleased to
present this program on business
and entrepreneurship in Saudi
Arabia; opportunities for partnering
and investing in emerging business.
But before we start today's program,
I'd like to give you a brief
overview of our division
and its resources in the
hopes that you return
and use our collections
for a research.
So, this is a custodial
division and what that means is
that we actually have the
books under our purview
and we have three sections that
build and serve the collections
to researchers from the world.
We cover over 78 countries
and over two dozen languages.
This African section includes the
countries of Sub-Saharan Africa,
the Hebrew's [phonetic] section is
responsible for Judoka [phonetic]
and Hebrewka [phonetic] worldwide.
And the new East section covers
all of the Arab countries,
including North Africa, Turkey,
Turkic [phonetic] Central Asia,
Iran, Afghanistan and the Muslims of
Western China, Russia, the Balkans
and the people of the Caucausic,
a very extensive region.
After the program, we invite you to
fill in a little evaluation forms
that you see in your seats because
this gives us an opportunity
to see what programs work well,
what you like and what you'd
like to see in the future.
We also invite you to
pick up our little form
about four corner's blog, with very
interesting post by our curators
as well as like us on Facebook
and that way you'll hear
about future programs.
And in addition to remind you this
program's being videotaped, so,
if you'd like to ask questions at
the end which we invite you to do.
But you're giving the
permission to be recorded.
So, now without further do, I'd like
to ask my colleague Nawal Kawar,
our Arab [Inaudible] specialist to
come up and introduce our speaker.
>> Nawal Kawar: Thank you Joan.
It is really my great pleasure to
introduce to you Mr. Edward Burton
and thank him and appreciate his
time, taking time from his work
to come and be with us today.
Mr. Burton is the present
president and chief executive
of the US Saudi Arabian
Business Council.
He works with the American and
South Republic and private sectors
to promote the interest of
the US Saudi Arabia bilateral
commercial relationship.
The main aim of the US Saudi
Arabian Business Council is
to improve the mutual
knowledge and understanding
between the private sectors of both,
the United States and Saudi Arabia.
The council's function is to
promote trade and investment
between the two countries
by utilizing
and targeting specialized bilateral
trade and investment opportunities
in the US and the Saudi Kingdom.
The US Saudi Arabian Business
council was established in 1993,
has been sponsoring advance in
activities such as trade missions,
conferences, seminars, forums
and high level networking
between business partners.
I hope they'll be invited
to one of them.
For example, the three US
Saudi opportunities forums held
in Chicago, Atlanta and Los Angeles
in 2010, 2011 and 2013 respectively;
were the largest gatherings of
Saudi and American businesses
in the history of the council's work
which at this to the strong ties
between the two business
communities.
That is US and Saudi Arabia.
Mr. Burton holds a bachelor
of arts [phonetic] degree
in political science from
the University of Charleston,
and a doctor of jurisprudence degree
from Dickenson [phonetic]
School of Law.
He practiced law in New Jersey
with the law firm Cooper Levinson.
He also received certified
international trade
and management training
at the Thunderbird School
of International Business
and the Harvard Business
School for Publishing.
Mr. Burton was Director of US Expert
Assistant Center in Philadelphia.
Prior to joining the US
Department of Commerce,
he served former New Jersey Governor
Christine Tad [phonetic] Whitman
as the Director of the State
of New Jersey's [phonetic]
International Trade Office.
Mr. Burton also served
as the Commercial Attaché
at the American Embassy
in Riyadh, Saudi Arabia.
He managed [inaudible] specialist
and other local direct higher
personal serving offices
in the cities of Riyadh,
[inaudible] and Teheran.
He was responsible for all US
foreign commercial services,
US FCS .
Operations in Saudi Arabia and had
oversight over all US FCS management
and physical [phonetic] matters
in the US embassy and consulates
in the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia.
He also supervised US FCS
operation in Manama, Bahrein,
through a partnership arrangement
with the US embassy in Manama.
Mr. Burton was also appointed
by former US Commerce
Secretary Donald Evans to serve
as the US FCS Regional Coordinator
for the agencies Iraq [phonetic]
reconstruction regional initiative.
Mr. Burton has counselled hundreds
of Fortune 500 companies as well
as small and middle
capitalized firms from a variety
of industries such as oil and gas.
[Inaudible], petrochemical,
construction, medical, defense
and security, information
technology and technical services.
He is the author of the book,
"Business and Entrepreneurship
in Saudi Arabia" Published by
the best company, John Wiley
and Sons in August 2-0-1-6, 2016.
The book is available for purchase
and books signing after the event.
Please help me welcome
Mr. Ed Burton.
[ Applauses ]
>> Edward Burton: Thank
you very much Nawal
for those introductory remarks, I
think they're almost the same length
of my remarks, but I thank
you for that introduction.
It's a pleasure professionally to
be here in the Library of Congress,
I thank you Nawal, I thank
you Joan [inaudible] division
for sponsoring today's event and
to be able to share your lunch hour
with you, to focus
on my book, "Business
and Entrepreneurship
in Saudi Arabia".
I have some prepared remarks but
I'd probably will [inaudible] them
with a couple of comments
and observations from --
most from my time with the
embassy in Riyadh and my time
with the US Saudi Arabian
Business Council.
Before I begin to speak about
the substance of my book,
allow me to address what I'm sure
is probably the most asked question
of authors, particularly
after their first book
and this is my first
literary project.
Why did you write your book?
So, the answer to that
question has to do
with where my professional career
has taken me over the last 16 years
as well as the body of
literature having to do
with the business community
and Saudi Arabia.
So, first in terms of
my professional life.
I landed in Riyadh in the
middle of the summer in 2003
for the beginnings of my diplomatic
posting as Commercial Attaché
at the American embassy
in Saudi Arabia.
From the moment I landed,
the stellar professionals
at the US commercial service
under the US Department
of Commerce took me under their
wings and made it their business
for the following three
years to introduce me to just
about every business person of
significance in Saudi Arabia
and made it their business so
that those businesses knew me,
those business leaders knew me
and the importance of the work
that the US commercial service
does in champing the interest
of American companies
in Saudi Arabia.
Having joined the US Saudi Arabian
Business Council 10 years ago,
I continued the journey with the
Saudi businesses and my respect
and admiration for
this important part
of the global corporate community
has only grown in measure.
So, to provide the first
answer to that question,
"Why I wrote the book", in large
measure was to repay the value
to my own professional
career that sustained contact
with the business community
has brought me.
Secondly, although there has
been much written on Saudi Arabia
over the last couple of decades,
there have been few books dedicated
to the subject of business,
businesses in Saudi Arabia.
As I mentioned in my book, a
cursorily [phonetic] review of books
about Saudi Arabia have primarily
centered on oil, geo politics,
the Saudi economy or social issues
such as the role and importance
of the lives of women
in Saudi Arabia.
There've been few books aimed and
accurately depicting the vibrant
and dynamic nature of the
Saudi business community
and what they do for the country.
So, I wanted to write a book
that directed predominantly
to western audience that
portrait the Saudi business sector
as vigorously engaged in global
markets, industrially diverse
and a corporate community that
is unified in their support
for the national values and
goals of the Saudi people.
The most mentioned Saudi company
in the world press these days
and actually in any
press or at any time
for that matter is Saudi Aramco, the
largest oil company in the world.
Saudi Aramco sizes
operations in oil production,
far out paces the world's next
four oil companies combined.
The company has been in
the press a lot lately due
to the anticipated
initial public offering
that is expected next year, in 2018.
The company is of course one, you
know, of the most prolific in terms
of not only upstream
production of oil but as well
as downstream production and
many people don't know but much
of the oil that flows through
the pumps and gasoline stations
of growing amount is from Saudi
Aramco's, a joint venture operations
in Port Arthur, the
refinery down in Texas.
So, when Saudi Aramco
takes an expected 5%
of that company public
it is anticipated
to be the largest IPO in history.
Now, just to give you
some perspective,
the largest IPO today is Ali
Baba's September 2014 IPO
that [inaudible] the company
proceeds of 25 billion dollars.
The next largest in
history before that was
when the credit card
company Visa went public
in 2008 netting [phonetic]
in $17.9 billion.
So, the process of valuating
Saudi Aramco's assets is ongoing,
however at this time some analysts
project the value of those assets
of Saudi Aramco to be between
one and two trillion dollars.
So, it is expected that the proceeds
from Saudi Aramco's IPO will reach
at least $100 billion
when the IPO occurs.
But to my book.
Business is much more
than Saudi Aramco
and Saudi basic industries
corporation Sabic, which is also one
of the largest petrochemical
companies in the world.
Although those companies
consistently pose some
of the largest capital
spending in Saudi Arabia,
there are other segments of the
Saudi Arabic corporate society
of equally important economic
value to the country and essential
to the current government's
plans to restructure
and diversify its economy.
So, I wanted to write a book about
Saudi Arabia's family on businesses
and the betting young
entrepreneurship
that is occurring in Saudi Arabia.
I wanted to highlight a few of
the well-known corporate figures
who are owners of the large
family on businesses as well
as to draw attention to some
of the rising Saudi
entrepreneurs within the Kingdom.
I did not want to write a book
to contain dry facts and figures
of how these businesses
contribute to the health
and stability of the nation solely.
Rather I wanted to bring to life
the personalities and opinions
of these business owners, again
to primarily a western audience
to quite frankly many find
Saudi Arabia quite enigmatic.
And even businesses that are
doing business there find it
sometimes enigmatic.
There is a continuum in the life of
Saudi Arabia's business community
from business owners that
started their family businesses
in the 1940s, 50s and early 1960s.
To today Saudi's youth that have
innovative startups and companies
with disruptive technologies that
are having a global impact to some
of the older business leaders,
sometimes referred to as,
"The old guard ", they are many
of these older people and as well
as the young people, are really
re-crafting how business is being
done in Saudi Arabia.
So, I wanted to portrait that,
many of these older business owners
and some of these Saudi
own [phonetic] businesses,
the larger Saudi own businesses
are multinational conglomerates
with businesses interests in many
countries including United States.
So, many of their first-generation
family on business owners,
like Sheik of [inaudible] the
former Central Bank Governor
of the country.
And actually, one of our business
councils, former Saudi Co-Chairman,
are venerated and respected
within Saudi Arabia.
Yet among this continuum,
there are the raising,
second and third generation
family on business members
that are starting to assume
leadership authority in many
of these companies and
are making their own marks
within the Saudi business community.
So, I think, in part, the especial
character of my book is attributed
to the degree to which these family
own businesses really opened their
doors to me during the research
phase and writing of my book.
Particularly, Sheik of [inaudible]
and his brothers, and their company
which was formed in 1958.
They gave me an exclusive
look inside their companies,
I featured three companies
in my book.
And all three permitted
me interviews
with not only the older generations,
the founders of these companies
but also their sons and in
some cases their daughters
that are taking over their business.
As I have presented the opinions of
these younger generational family
on business leaders, I believe
that they do add significant value
to my book and make
it worth reading.
So, since I've already started to
talk about the contents of my book
by telling you why I wrote it, let
me take some time and tell you more
about the substantive
messages in the book.
I would like to use the remaining
time just to take you through some
of the select chapters and
highlight some of the subjects
and important themes I believe
that make the book worth reading.
In the book's introduction, I
open with a very small vignette,
featuring Sheik of Duragman
[phonetic], Al Reisi [phonetic].
Sheik of Duragman is one of the
most respected business leaders
in Saudi Arabia and I open
up my book with this vignette
and his track as a
7-year-old boy in 1940,
travelling from his ancestral home
of Raghbah Saudi Arabia
to Riyadh by camel.
Raghbah is about 75 miles
from the center of Riyadh.
Sheik of Duragman, Al Reisi is just
a stellar individual and is chairman
of the Jurisi [phonetic] group,
which is one of the largest
companies in Saudi Arabia.
It is a Sabic conglomerate
with business interests
all over the world.
He's also the former chairman
of the Council of Saudi Chambers
of commerce and Industry,
which is the umbrella chamber
for the country.
As well as the chairman of the
Riyadh Chamber for many years.
So, a couple of years ago I
was at Sheik of Duragman's home
for dinner one evening
along with other American
and Saudi business people.
During the dinner, Sheik of Duragman
retold the story of his early days
as a youth in Riyadh in the 1940s.
He told his dinner
guests of the time
when Riyadh was essentially
a small village
that went to sleep at sun down.
I used Sheik of Duragman's story
of travelling to Riyadh as a boy
because it serves as a
common example of how many
of today's headlined private
and public sector leaders
began their journey
from their modest homes and made
their ways to cities like Riyadh,
Jeddah and the old cities of the
eastern province such as [inaudible]
to seek their careers,
education and fortune.
I also used that story he told
that evening to contrast the city
of Riyadh as it was before the
creation of this modern Saudi state
and how it has become
a global city today.
Along with Sheik of Duragman's
story, I sight two years
of the most important
to the city of Riyadh.
1902 and 1932.
In 1902 the founder of the modern
Saudi State [Inaudible] reclaimed
the city of Riyadh and used its
strategically center location
in the country to launch a
three decades long struggle
to unify the tribes of
the Arabian Peninsula.
King Abdul-Aziz [phonetic] began
his unification on horseback,
however in 1907 it is believed
that the first automobile
eventually landed in the Kingdom,
one of the first in
the Arabian Peninsula.
The king was one of the first,
of course to receive
these new machines.
The automobile was definitely
used by King Abdul-Aziz
and his national unification
efforts and later
in executing the many
diplomatic missions he undertook
around the country and you
see some of these photographs,
just go back just a couple.
You see King Abdul-Aziz is arriving
in Jeddah in 1931 and there is a --
next photograph -- is King
Abdul-Aziz and Prince Faisal
on an inspection of the oil wells
in 1947 and the last photograph
of course illustrates how the
automobile allowed King Abdul-Aziz
to discharge his diplomatic
duties as head of state.
And you see the king here, with
the leading Syrian politician
of the day Mardem Bey
in Taif in 1934.
So, the automobile and particularly
American manufactured automobile
parts were an inedible part of the
beginning of the modern Saudi State.
The other important year in
the life of Riyadh was 1932,
I mention this in the book.
The year the sovereign Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia was established.
That year marked the
turning point for the city,
which began a slow growth in terms
of population and national
prominence.
It is interesting to note that
in 1932, at the declaration
of sovereignty of the country,
the nation was among one
of the most poor on
the face of the Earth.
And it was largely a desert where
the kingdom's only major source
of revenue came from pilgrims
visiting Islam's holiest cities.
So, just to close on
my thoughts with Sheik
of Duragman's dinner table
discussion that ultimately led
to my devoting my book's
introduction to him,
I would like to read a
couple of short paragraphs,
actually one paragraph
relating to the city
of Riyadh as it was back then.
Riyadh, the Riyadh of 1902 was
no more than a mile across,
it consisted of the
Masmat [phonetic],
the citadel that was also the seat
of government, a large Masque,
a spacious market place
and several hundred houses,
all built of mud brick.
The entire city was surround
the by a thick mud wall,
ranging as high as 25 feet.
The city's famous day gardens were
many located outside the walls.
Sheik of Duragman recounts his
story of his youth in Riyadh
that when the end came for
[inaudible] prayer, the night time
and last of the daily prayers
recited by practicing Muslims,
the city would shut
itself from the night
by close the main gate
to those outside.
The Riyadh of the time of young
Duragman's arrival is not the Riyadh
of today.
In 1940, there were not overhead
electricity transmission lines,
no power stations or
state power regulator.
No light bulbs were to be found
in most Saudi homes, mosques
or commercial establishments.
If one had looked in earnest
[phonetic] electricity could have
been found in some of the
palaces of the royal family.
Electrical power generation
and the mass distribution
of electricity came to Saudi
Arabia in Riyadh in 1951
with the establishment
of the kingdom's first public
utility Riyadh electricity company.
During Sheik of Duragman's time
in Riyadh growing up in the 1940s,
there were few of them,
3,000 city inhabitants
and the economy was
primarily composed of merchant
and agrarian commercial activity.
And the business of
course of local government.
Today the city has
5.7 million people.
And this is Riyadh
actually in the 20 --
around the 1920s or 30s and this
is the view of the same location,
Qasr al-Hukm as it is today.
So, today 5.7 million people and
a population growth rate of 4%.
Its economy is one of the
most industrially diverse
in the Middle East and its city
gross products is estimated
to be more than $17 billion.
And you saw some pictures
of old Riyadh and old Riyadh
and the big dig referencing
the big dig embossment
of years ago is happening in Riyadh
with the construction of the metro.
So, hopefully if any of you have
been to Dubai and you've seen
that beautiful metro that they have,
Saudi Arabia's building
their own version.
So, I'll make mention --
short mention of chapter one which
covers the period 1938 to 1970,
a critical period in
Saudi Arabia's history
when the discovery of oil occurred.
Now, here you see the
momentous Dammam number seven,
the first commercially viable
oil well in Saudi Arabia.
During this time, the creation
of the kingdom's administrative
governmental structures were formed,
then the humble beginnings of some
of Saudi Arabia's most iconic family
own businesses got off the ground.
In chapter one I introduce one of
the current things of the book,
and one that I believe
has been essential --
is essential to the success
of the kingdom's effort
to grow the country's economy
namely, is the question
of whether there is adequate
coordination between government
and the private sector at all levels
in pursuing the country's
development goals.
One of the most important
event occurring in the kingdom
within the last 15 years that has
had international significance
for the country has been
Saudi Arabia's accession
to the world trade
organization, WTO.
Saudi Arabia's membership in the WTO
was preceded by a very lively debate
in the country about the
impact of WTO membership
to the nation's private sector.
During the 1960s and 70s there
were many import substitution laws
and in enact of Saudi Arabia
to protect its domestic market
from foreign competition.
As the country's lead
WTO negotiators began
to bargain away some of
those protectionist laws,
Saudi businesses began
to be more vocal
in the press expressing their
extreme unease over some
of the new measures that
were aimed at opening
up the Saudi market to
foreign competition.
The government was obligated to take
these measures in order to join WTO.
There were dire warning from some
within Saudi Arabia's
business community
that industrial development
projects would fail,
many Saudi companies would face
financial ruin if the Kingdom were
to go through with
that membership in WTO.
In the years prior to WTO
accession, Saudi Arabian erected 42,
19 which were required
for WTO admission.
So, in my book I conclude that
much of the high anxiety exhibited
by the Saudi businesses
was probably unwanted,
to be sure some Saudi business
were negatively impacted
by the WTO accession, however
there is evidence that suggests
that WTO membership actually
boosted the kingdom's effort
to diversify its economy.
The opening of the economic markets
to foreign investors
has also undoubtedly led
to more technology transfer,
sharing of industrial processes
and the funding of proprietary
innovation applications inside
the kingdom.
So, net net it is has
been a positive.
Chapter two of my book offers a
broad view of the surprising amount
of innovation taking
place in the kingdom.
It is important to know that Saudi
Arabia's journey towards cultural
advancement in technology
and innovation has its roots
in the illustrious past of
Islamic research and discovery.
I make mention of this in the
very first paragraph of my book
and if you would allow me, I want
to read just a short
paragraph from that.
Invention and worldwide
impact contributions
to science are nothing new
to the Islamic world during
the [inaudible] dynasty 750
to 258 Islamic culture, arts
and scientific advancements
reached its apex.
The vertex of this pinnacle legacy
of achievement was the undeniable
fact that the world's economy
at that time benefited enormously
from the furtive and creative minds
of Islamic theorists, scholars
and scientists resident
in the Dynasty's capital, Bagdad.
Largest donations and
contributions given
to fund the scientific pursuits of
Muslim intellectuals from Bagdad
and throughout the Islamic
Empire stretching from Asia
to Southern Europe helped to advance
an already flourishing economic
and commercial trading emporium.
So, I mentioned that because
although, you know, the impact
and global implications of the
research and development occurring
in Saudi Arabia is certainly
not as globally widespread
as the economy benefits
the Islamic world derived
from the epicedian [phonetic]
innovations 14 centuries ago.
Nevertheless, in chapter two
I discuss the Saudi pursuit
of innovation and invention.
I especially know when it comes
to actualizing the development
of technological advancement within
the kingdom, much of the discourse
in Saudi Arabia has centered
on innovation as opposed
to the concept of invention.
Chapter two devotes considerable
time to discussing the importance
between the difference between
innovation and invention.
And at the most technology
experts and historians agree
that invention is not
the same as innovation.
And to put it simply, invention
is always in the first instance
and what follows in terms of
improving to the original thing is
in some form or another innovation.
So, the tip of the spear
organizations leading Saudi Arabia
forward, in both innovation
and invention
such as King Abdul University
for science and technology
or [inaudible] as it's called.
King Abdul-Aziz City for science and
technology or KACST, as it's known.
The national [inaudible] office and
others are discussed in chapter two
and their importance to bringing new
technologies and inventions forward.
Chapter three actually is perhaps
my favorite chapter in the book
because it discusses in detail
the Saudi Family on businesses.
The chapter discusses the
enduring legacy of these businesses
and gives the reader
a rare look at several
of the country's most
respected family establishments.
The research of this chapter
entailed hours of interviews
with founders and first
generation, second generation,
third generation family members,
as well as covering published
and unpublished literature
on how these businesses
have historically operated
in the country, in the
peninsula and globally.
Saudi family on businesses are
very much defined of course
by the cultural norms
and historical standards
on how businesses operate
in the country.
By nature of the cultural
[inaudible] of Saudi society,
the internal operations
and management
of these companies have
been closed to outsiders.
However, since the late 1960s,
a Saudi family own
businesses have taken
on foreign joined venture partners
and formed the separate businesses
as well as holding companies to
manage their spare businesses
in the kingdom and worldwide.
The composition of the boards
of these family own businesses,
therefore have changed and evolved.
As boards which once were
dominated only by family members,
fathers first generation
family members to one
in which you have senior executives
from largely western companies,
some Asian companies sitting on
these boards and as well as second
and third generation family members
who have taken their
place at the board table.
So, I discussed this in the
book and the evolving nature
of doing business with
Saudi own businesses,
particularly from the
perspective of American companies.
And I had the pleasure of convincing
the law firm Crimorean [phonetic]
to have a section in the book which
discusses some of the legal aspects
that American companies should be
aware of when they get into business
with these Saudi own businesses.
Chapter three discusses what
happens when one or more
of these original founders
of a decade's old family
own business dies
or wishes to leave the business.
Often these original
founders were the guiding
and authoritarian forces
behind the company's growth
and success over many decades.
So, I'm particularly pleased that
I was able to get the opinions
of the younger generation of
family own business leaders
on how they view the transition
from the company's original
leadership often led
by their fathers or uncles to
the second and third generation
of Saudi's eager to take their
place and managing the businesses.
I have to tell you the most
fun I had in writing this book
and researching the book
is within chapter four.
Since my book examines the subject
of entrepreneurship in Saudi Arabia
and how the country promotes
and supports its entrepreneurial
ecosystem, I spent some time
in researching the organizations
and institutions in Saudi Arabia
that are dedicated to supporting
the entrepreneurial ecosystem.
Moreover, I've looked at the
hundreds of millions of dollars
that Saudi Arabia spends
every year to support small
and medium size enterprises and
the entrepreneurial ecosystem.
So, in chapter four
look at the question
as to whether Saudi Arabia has
thrown money at the question
of Saudi SMEs and I
look at the efficacy
of the many government funded
agencies that have been created
to support small and
medium size businesses
and entrepreneurship in the country.
So, most startups in Saudi Arabia
are started by Saudi youth.
And it's important
to note that with 70%
of the Saudi population
being below the age of 25,
the government is highly
incentivized
to support this ecosystem.
Because many Saudis of the younger
generation are looking at business
as a way to further their lives'
pursuits as opposed to historically
which has been the
instability of government jobs.
A big part of the relevancy
of that question is what is the
definition of the entrepreneur?
And that was one of the primary
purposes in looking at the subject,
because if you're just
throwing money at a problem
without knowing what
is an entrepreneur
or who you should be helping,
who call themselves entrepreneurs
for the overall betterment
of the economy,
then you are may be
missing the mark.
So, in chapter four I give the
reading a sweeping historical view
of the term of entrepreneur.
From some of the earliest uses of
the term, an attempt of definition
such as those of celebrated
18th to 19th century economist
and authors Richard
Cotillion, and JP say.
I think you'll all find it a very
entertaining joint [phonetic]
that includes the financial
bankruptcy of France
under Luis the 14th, the
son's King [phonetic].
America's Louisiana Purchase and
onto today's view of what it means
to take risk as an entrepreneur
and re-profits from the pursuit.
I'll briefly mention chapter five,
although is probably the most
important chapter when it comes
to today's Saudi business people.
In this chapter I interview three
of Saudi Arabia's most insightful
and thoughtful entrepreneurs.
I explore the theme
visited throughout my book,
which is the central theme and that
is the issue of the fear of failure.
The consequences to Saudi
entrepreneurs who start a business
and subsequently fail are not
normally what they are for startups
and entrepreneurs in
the western world.
They -- when you start a
business, in Saudi Arabia and --
I would say primarily
in the Arab world,
the specter of failure can
haunt you for a lifetime.
Is it not as it is view
in the western culture,
particularly in the Silicon Valley
failure, viewed as a badge of honor
which is to be warned,
and can catapult you
to further startups
and other activities.
In Saudi Arabia, although
it is changing,
in my interviews I did
honored that in many instances.
The cultural and societal
concept of failure,
particularly for entrepreneurs
is changing
and slowly becoming more acceptable.
But today it can be a real stigma
and when you have bank loans
or you go to lending institutions
for a startup and you fail,
you most certainly will be
blacklisted in going into the future
in terms of seeking further
capital start your business.
So, we're quite proud at the
business council for a number
of years we have worked
with young entrepreneurs
as you see are depicted here.
We worked with the King Salman
Youth Center for a number of years.
Bringing groups of young Saudi
entrepreneurs to the United States,
to different cities so
that they get exposure
to the various corporate
communities here, in fact I think
that we even took them to
the New York Stock Exchange
when they're ringing the bell,
which was pretty neat for them.
So, lastly to move to the close
of my remarks I, you know,
would like to talk
about chapter six.
Which is basically putting together
all of the many things that I have
in the book in terms of
the Kingdom's current plans
to transform the Saudi economy
from one predominantly dependent
on oil revenues to a
more diversified one
which provides employment
to all studies seeking it
in a more rejuvenated, entertained
and more healthy Saudi society.
In April of last year Saudi King
Salman [inaudible] proposed a
comprehensive plan for
the Kingdom's economic
and social growth and change.
The plan is known as, "Vision
2030" and it is the most ambitious
and detailed economic development
project the Saudi government has
ever undertaken.
And if you read my book, almost
from the first chapter I talk
about throughout the book the
economic development plans
over the decades that have
transformed the economy
of Saudi Arabia.
This is the latest and greatest
and it was begun last year
and financial analysts,
country study experts are all
intently looking at Saudi Arabia
to see how their progress
would go and it should be noted
that there are other countries
in the gulf Oman and a couple
of others have already done
their version of Vision 2030.
But Saudi Arabia being the
largest economy in the gulf,
it's being intently scrutinized
as to where it would go.
So, this plan if ultimately
successful will have long term
and profound implication
for a number
of the country's critical
important industry sectors.
The vision also calls
for the reformation
of how the country
lives, stays healthy
and enjoys itself in recreation.
Among the goals of 2030 and I'll
just mentioned a few of them here,
by this plan if successful they will
increase the average life expectancy
of Saudis from 74 years to 80 years.
If successful, they hope to
lower the rate of unemployment
from currently 11.6% to 7% and
significantly lower the rate
of Saudi women unemployed,
which is actually double the
national average.
They also want to increase small and
medium size enterprise contribution
to the GDP from currently
20% to 35%.
Again, with going back to women,
to increase women's participation
in the workforce from 22% to 30%.
To move -- they want to move the
current position of Saudi Arabia
from the 19th largest
economy to the 12th.
And that is a heavy lift,
but considering they are the
only Arab country in the G20,
it may not be a heavy lift.
If they are successful, they want to
increase foreign direct investment
from 3.8% to the international
level standard of 5.7% of GDP.
And a couple of more, to increase
the sector's contribution from 40%
to 65% of GDP and to raise
the share of not oil exports
in the non-oil GDP from 16% to 50%.
Those last two, and I talk
about this throughout the book,
I believe that in order for
the Kingdom to be successful
in Vision 2030, it is
actually crucial that they get
by from the country's
private sector.
And these companies, many of
them family own businesses
and global corporations that have
assets all around the world to bring
that capital spending from other
markets back into Saudi Arabia
to take off a lot of the capital
spending that are currently
on the government's books is
what the kingdom wants to do.
So, those foreign investors
are already in the kingdom --
particularly American investors are
solidly behind the country's efforts
to transform the country.
In the last chapter of my book,
I recount a meeting that was held
on the sidelines of King Abdul-Aziz
-- King Salman, excuse me --
King Salman's visit to
Washington in September 2015.
I had the privilege of sort
of being a gadfly in the room
and I named some of these Fortune
500 chairmen and CEOs who were
around the table in the book and
you know, being having worked
in the business world for
a while and seen people,
I'm not easily impressed, but the
group that was there with three
of the Saudi ministers
was pretty heady.
And I talk about that in the book,
you have to read the book to find
out what they said,
but I can tell you
that these American businesses
were solidly behind Vision 2030,
they had some concerns and
expressed some opinions as to some
of the difficulties they encountered
in Saudi Arabia but by large,
they are all in of course in
having in some instances hundreds
of millions and billions of dollars
already invested in Saudi Arabia
with the Kingdom and its companies.
They want to see them succeed.
So, I think with that I will just
briefly mention my current employer,
the US Saudi Arabian
Business Council,
it's hard to believe I've been
there for 10 years already.
But of course, we're membership
organization, we're quite privileged
to -- if you look at our
board of directors, I mean,
you'll see some stellar individuals
that just the CEO Saudi Aramco,
many of the captains of
industry in Saudi Arabia as well
as an equal number of Fortune
500 company chairmen and CEOs
and senior executives that
are on our board and moreover,
if you look at our
membership, what I tried to do
when I joined the business
council 10 years ago was
to grow a [inaudible] of
medium and small enterprises,
because it was predominantly, it
was dominated by the large companies
and we've been very successful
in bringing in more small
and medium sized companies with
these technologies and services
that are finding market
receptivity in Saudi Arabia.
So, we're pleased with that, you
see here on the slide the range
of our services, from customized
business advisory services
to print it indigital material
that talks about what's going
on economically in the country,
to market sector reports
and even Visa services,
you still need a Saudi Visa
to go to Saudi Arabia.
So, with that again let me
thank the library of congress
for the opportunity to highlight
my book and I'd be happy
to answer any questions, thank you.
[ Applauses ]
Anything, yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Edward Burton: So, story on that.
In 2013, some of you may
know the kingdom is trying
to build automobiles.
And that's one of their aspirations
because of the downstream
petrochemical industry
in Saudi Arabia, a lot of the car
parts that are made have some type
of input material from
plastic to some metals,
but mostly downstream
petrochemical material.
So, what we did with
the kingdom was,
we organized an automobile
conference just outside Detroit
and we, -- you know, we had about
a couple hundred people there,
but we had to do some
research to have some
of the presentations
that were given.
So, automobiles, that's a research
on automobiles, I - will no,
now that I have your card, I would
go back to our folks and find
out where those photographs came
from, couple of them came from,
actually from some of
the auto manufacturers.
So, the big four, or the big
three, you know, were there,
they're senior executives
from Ford, GM and others
and we requested some
photographs from them,
so some of them actually
came from I think GM,
or the one with the [inaudible],
but I'll find out for you.
OK. Yes, Joan, yes..
>> I was fascinated
with [inaudible].
Little bit on women [inaudible] by
women and also what is the status
of women in the younger sector
as far as entrepreneurship,
are they beginning to startup small
businesses and how does that relate
to some of the US small businesses
that [inaudible] minority
[inaudible].
>> Edward Burton: So,
women are dynamic
and prolific business
owners of Saudi Arabia.
What you used to hear, which is
quite true in Saudi Arabia is
that -- you know, while the
gentlemen have these positions
in government and in
other positions,
they have these business
that they run.
And the women that take care of
those businesses are their wives,
their daughters and so,
years back, decades back,
women started holding their
business skills a long time ago.
It's been within the last
I'd say 15 years that --
maybe 20 but probably 15 that
an amazing amount of startups
in Saudi Arabia are
women own businesses.
It's really a truly
interesting story because in some
of the interviews that I've
had, you'll speak with women --
of course, as you know Saudi Arabia
is a gender segregated society
and so, women are not -- still
not adequately represented in many
of the upper echelons of
Saudi Administrative offices,
government offices.
So, these women, you know, they have
had difficult waters to navigate
in order to set up businesses
and they are truly intrepid
in their spirit because they
get it done, they, you know,
I've heard of stories
where not taking no
for an answer was a bit dramatic
but these women, they get it done,
they get their businesses formulated
or created and they go forward,
the debate in the kingdom in terms
of the entrepreneurial ecosystem
and women have to do with
who you should be helping.
So, these women on businesses
range from very creative clothing
and accessories, you know, the
colorful vibes, the jewelry --
you know, cupcake industries - Ii
went to an [inaudible] a couple
of months ago in the
eastern province
and it was just mind spinning,
because it was an [inaudible] solely
for women that was a
building of two floors,
many businesses were
started, you had a lady there
that started her own
Aude [phonetic] company,
which is the perfume prevalent
in the Middle East,
cologne if you're a guy.
Very expensive, I mean these are
very expensive, this lady makes them
for royalty and they go from, you
know over a few hundred dollars
to a couple of thousand
dollars for a small bottle.
Cupcake manufacturers, I
had to run out of there
because one was a chocolatier and I
kept eating these things and I said,
"I've got to get out of here" , but
these women, they're just amazing.
So, the question in Saudi Arabia
now is, "Do we help these women
or do we try to get
the women that are
in family own businesses are
ready spin out and have operations
that are much larger economic
consequence to the Kingdom.
So, that's going on, but
they are truly amazing.
I hope I answered your question.
Yes
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Edward Burton: So,
you need to buy my book.
Yeas, I spent a good deal of time
talking about technology patenting
and interview Mr. Sodus [phonetic]
who runs the national patent office.
Spent a number of hours with him and
some of his colleagues and I talked
about the evolution of patent,
the patent process in Saudi Arabia
and it is improving, I mean it
used to take an incredible amount
of time, year and a half, two years
to patent something and longer.
Now they have done to months
and they're passionate
about bringing efficiency
to the process.
A lot of the patents are
coming in from young Saudis,
many of them coming through --
matriculating through
the universities.
Through the incubators
but they are --
the process is discussed
very extensively in my book.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Edward Burton: It's the same,
it's normally you'll find
universities that have incubators
where they take in applications
from Saudis, many of them students
but they don't have to be.
They make these applications to
have access to physical facilities
where they make available to these
young entrepreneurs the hardware,
the equipment, in many instances
a lot of the soft research
and resources that are
available within the institutions
to help them bring to market --
commercialize their
patents, their ideas.
And so, many of the companies,
including one, very famous lady,
that made Arabic coffee
maker that is Saudi Arabic
that they make an instant
coffee maker is selling --
what is her name?
[Inaudible] It's in the book.
She's -- But those are
examples of technologies
and commercialized business products
that came out of incubators.
The same concept in the west.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Edward Burton: Yes.
So, that's one of the misconceptions
of -- maybe deserved 30 --
you know 15, 20 years
ago but no so much now.
So, the perception is that women,
American women, western women going
to Saudi Arabian, can't
get in the country,
they can't get visas,
they can't do business.
There are certain visa requirements
for instance for married women,
you know, you have to certain
information [inaudible] no, no, no,
they don't have to be
married, but, you know,
on the visa application they
have to basically document
that you're married, but when I
was Commercial Attaché for instance
for 2003 to 2006 I heard that and
yet for almost the entire
three years that I was there,
almost every month or every other
month we'd see these executives,
female executives from American
companies coming in, landing,
doing their two to three days'
worth of business and going out
and having no difficulty whatsoever
and that's only improved
over the years.
Thank you so much.
[Applauses]
>> This has been a presentation
of the library of congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov